welcome back in this presentation I'm
just going to do a bunch of examples of
taking the antiderivative or the
indefinite integral of polynomial
expressions and and and hopefully I'll
show you that it's a pretty
straightforward thing to do so let's
let's get started let's see if I wanted
to take the indefinite integral
indefinite integral and you could you
could do a web search for integral and
you'll see this drawn properly take the
indefinite integral of let me let me
make something a big expression let's
say I want to take the indefinite
integral of 3x to the negative 5 minus 7
X to the 3rd plus 3 minus X to the 9th
so you you might already be intimidated
by what I wrote down
well 1 if you saw the last presentation
if you understood left British you
probably realize well the indefinite
integral even though it looks like fancy
math isn't that fancy or at least it is
into that difficult to perform and all
you have to realize now is when we took
the derivative if we took the derivative
of of a polynomial was just the sum of
the derivatives of each of the terms and
that actually turns it's actually is it
turns out is the same way the other way
around the antiderivative of this entire
expression is just the sum of the anti
derivatives of each of the individual
terms so we can just take the
antiderivative each term and we'll get
the answer so what is this equal well in
this case 3x to the minus 5 power so we
take the exponent we add one to the
exponent so now we get X to the negative
4 right X to the minus 4 and then we
multiply the coefficient times 1 over
the new the new exponent so 1 over the
new exponent is minus 1/4 right so 3
times minus 1/4 is minus 3/4
and let's see here we have X to the
third so instead of X to the third let's
raise it by one number so we get X to
the fourth and then we multiply the
coefficient you know we could either
just keep the minus and say the
coefficient seven or we could just say
the coefficient is minus seven we
multiply the coefficient times one over
the new exponent so the new exponent is
4 so it's we multiply 1/4 times 2 minus
7 so minus seven over four and now this
is interesting
well three three just three well how do
how do we apply this well is it three
the same thing as 3 times X to the zero
right because extra zero is just one and
that's how you should view it and it
shows you that this rule is actually
very consistent so what's the
antiderivative of three well if we view
3 as 3 X to the 0 we raise the exponent
by 1 so now we're going to have X to the
1 right and X to the 1 is just X so I'm
just going to leave it as an X and we
multiply it the old coefficient is 3 or
the you know the derivative coefficient
we multiply that times 1 over the
inverse of this new code the new
exponent so the X plus 1 so the inverse
of 1 is 1 so it just stays 3 right we we
divided we multiplied 3 times 1 over 1
which is still just 3 and then finally X
to the ninth I think you're getting the
hang of this we raise the exponent by 1
X to the 10th and then we multiply the
current coefficient well the current
coefficient is minus 1 right we just
didn't write the 1 there we multiply the
current coefficient minus 1 times 1 over
the new exponent so it's minus 1 over 10
there we did that wasn't too difficult
of taking the antiderivative or oh oh
once again high yes I always I always
forget plus C right because when you
take the derivative of any constant it
becomes 0 so it might have disappeared
here so plus C that word this is any
constant this could be a 10 it could be
a million could be a minus trillion it's
any constant and just to just to really
hit the point home let's take the
derivative of this and just make sure we
got this expression and this hopefully
is second nature to you by now and you
know if you ever run out of practice
problems in your book because you love
doing math so much just make up problems
that's what I'm doing alright I do this
even when I'm not recording videos just
for fun okay
so let's take the derivative this minus
four times this coefficient minus 4
times minus 3/4 is 3x then we subtract 1
from this exponent minus 5 and then
minus 7 4 times 4 is minus 7x to the
which we take one from this exponent X
1/3 and I promise you I'm not even
looking up here I know you might think
well Sal he's just looking up here but
no I'm actually in my head at least
working through this and then plus the
derivative of 3x well the derivative
three X's is 3 is almost like a nature
now but you can kind of do this as 3 X
to the 1 and you say 1 times 3 is 3
times X to the 0 right and then 10 times
minus 1/10 well that's just minus 1 X to
the 1 less than 10 X to the ninth plus
what's the derivative of any constant
right it's 0 all right you could you
could almost view this constant as you
know some number times you know X to the
0 and if you took the derivative well
you multiply the 0 times C and you get 0
and then well you might get minus 1
depending on how you're doing but that's
actually kind of an interesting question
okay I'll stop by digressing but you get
a 0 here and if you simplify that that
just equals 3x to the minus 5 minus 7 X
to the 3rd plus 3 minus X to the 9th
think we have time for one more problem
like this I think you've probably got
this this is probably one of the more
straightforward things you'll learn in
mathematics and in future presentations
I'll give you more of an intuition of
what you can actually why the
antiderivative is useful and then you
know using that we're learning the
indefinite integral but we could learn
to use the definite integral which we'll
learn in a cup
presentations to figure out things like
the area under curve or the volume of a
rotational figure well not only confuse
you too much let's do one more problem I
won't make this one as as hairy so the
integral of negative 1/2 X to the minus
3 plus 7 X to the fifth
well we let's start with this this term
of the polynomial we raise the exponent
1 so X to the minus 2 now right because
we just raised we added 1 to negative 3
and then we multiply 1 over this new
exponent times the old coefficient and
actually I'll write out all the steps so
the old coefficient is minus 1/2 right
the old coefficient is minus 1/2 let me
some colors so this is a minus 2 minus 2
so we multiply times minus 1/2 right and
then let me switch colors back plus we
raise the exponent by 1 X to the sixth
and we multiply the old coefficient
times 1 over the new coefficient times 1
over 6 it's multiplication yellow 6 and
so what's the answer
well what's minus 1/2 times minus 1/2
well that's positive 1/4 X to the minus
2 oh and of course plus C as you can
tell this was my main source of missing
points and on on calculus quizzes 1/4 X
to the minus 2 plus 7 6 X to the sixth
plus C there you go and if you want to
take the derivative minus 2 times 1/4 is
minus 2/4 which is minus 1/2 X to the
minus 3 and then 6 times 7 sixths is 7x
and then you decrease the exponent by 1
X to the fifth and
derivative of a constant is zero and
then we get our original expression so I
think hopefully at this point you're
pretty comfortable you know taking a
derivative taking a derivative of
polynomial and then give it a polynomial
you can actually take the antiderivative
go the other way and never forget to do
your plus C's and I hope you understand
why we have to put that constant there
because when you take an antiderivative
you don't know whether the original
thing that you took the derivative of I
guess had a constant there because the
constants derivative is zero
hopefully I confuse you with that last
statement I will see you the next
presentation and I'll show you how to
reverse the chain rule see you soon